and lo guys here again at this supper
suite at South by Southwest right now I
want to give a big shout-out to hint
water because we wouldn't be talking
about movies at South by Southwest if it
wasn't for our wonderful sponsors and
right now we get to talk about mother's
little helpers because of them hi guys
congratulations on the movie I am a
little sensitive when it cut everyone a
Collider knows I love horror movies but
I'm a little sensitive when it comes to
more realistic approaches to a situation
where someone's dying and the fact that
this movie kind of left me with a shred
of hope
it's something about the family vibe and
the chemistry that kind of really spoke
to me and I connected to you right from
the start so just to go back to the
beginning here where did this idea come
from and also I noticed that the cast
were all listed as co writers on the
film which struck me yeah the idea was
something I'd been sitting on for a few
years after I attended some group death
situations and mostly because a it's a
bummer but - it's also kind of awesome
and magical to have those moments of
human connection and I'm for me it's
hilarious I am always the one who will
end up laughing at the baby's funeral
like inappropriately and for me that's
what this movie really represented is
that like as humans we kind of only have
like so high of a threshold for for
tragedy and at a certain point we just
go insane and it becomes hysterical and
that was my authentic human experience
and when I started talking to my friends
my real-life friends Frieda and Sam
about that experience and wanting to
make this movie last year they had both
went through the exact same thing where
both of them lost their dad in the exact
same time frame almost on the exact same
day almost in the exact same way and
both of them really wanted to talk about
it we had these complicated sibling
coming together so I thought that I was
super special and unique and that you
know this like thing happened to me and
then I realized that it literally
happens to everyone most of us are never
going to be James Bond like Internet
we'll spy double engine ting but most of
us will experience like pretty much
best-case scenario the death of a flawed
parent and it was through this like
conversation with my friends that we
decided this is something we all wanted
to talk about and kind of bring to the
table that sense of connection that
comes with it and you know you see a lot
of these improvised movies like you know
like best my favorite films right like
40 year old virgin bastion show my
favorite movies right but all of those
movies were improvised by these insanely
talented cast members but one person
ended up getting the writing credit for
it so while we were working off of that
outline in a story that I wrote it just
seems like fair that since we were gonna
be making it up as we went along that
they should get a co-writing credit and
they gave us they gave me their soul I
give them a co-writing credit seems like
a fair deal and III personally had one
of the most creative inspiring wilds
like life altering art experiences
working on qestions movie because Karen
has sort of built herself as a lady a
creator a filmmaker from this I mean
this is only me speaking from the
outside looking at you and your life I'm
like I don't know if you're talking
about yourself this way but like her but
she has a bill that builds communities
in a way that I've never seen anybody
was such open-mindedness vigor and
collective sort of like here's a project
let's get it done let's do this you know
and then offers so much and that's sort
of reflected in her our VIP which is
like this karaoke RV which transports
you to another universe and so her set
was this very interesting place which
was like you know the story what lived
and grew from this collective bubbling
furtherance of shared human experience
and it allowed us as actors and creators
to talk about our personal lives talk
about the lives of our family members
and how they might have dealt with that
and talked about the lives of our
I play julia pride in the in the movie
and i'm like the old based on
everybody's older sister who hasn't
adjusted well but i had we keep joking
that we can't talk about this movie
without directly talking about our
family but you know i ended up learning
a lot about my sisters and learning a
lot about other people's experience with
grief other people's experience with
this moment in your life where
everything becomes magnified where all
of your failures all of your hopes
dreams become magnified in the death of
a parent and it's both like the most
beautiful time in your life and the most
adult but anyone who's experienced that
kind of loss knows it's like all of a
sudden time gets compressed and
experience gets compressed and you it's
like this strange feeling where you
wouldn't trade it for anything in the
world it's the worst time in your life
but you wouldn't want to ever skip it
it's a weird like and and our film is
kind of about you know capturing that
you know you try to avoid all these
things in your life and then when you
just have to stare directly into that
that scariness it's like the most
beautiful things can happen it's an
interesting thing to say that you
wouldn't want to skip it for the world
because like my mind immediately went to
how troubling it is to lose anyone a
family member or a pet but in that
moment the one thing that i always latch
on to is this feeling sucks but would I
give up all the good feelings to not
have to feel this and that kind of at
least levels it out yeah there's also I
think when you lose someone you're left
with the the people around you to kind
of identify yourself with and reflect
back who you are Who am I with this
person gone from my life and I feel like
we kind of explored that
yeah the vacuum that occurs in a in a
loss it's really fascinating I I think
that the biggest thing is that you know
these are all really big topics in there
that you know poets and
artists and everything have you know
world religions yeah don't forget talked
about this but I think what makes our
film so special is this very unique
energy that Kestrel has as a filmmaker
to bring out what other people are
experiencing and not in an obtrusive way
notnot like I'm gonna take what you are
and steal it you know it's you offer
your soul up to her and she goes great
now come get on my karaoke bus and let's
take you kind of a movement it like it's
sort of just an abundant open heart like
welcoming anyone who wants to come on
board and have fun really it is not a
bus the our VIP lounge is a karaoke RV
that is built inside it's a karaoke
lounge built inside of a customized RV
that rolls around and throws these
parties in in some ways it's like yeah
like a party bus and it's like no not
like a party bus it is a time machine
that transports you to 4 a.m. in the
morning screaming at the top of your
lungs having the greatest night of your
entire life and there's a community
that's formed around it over the last 10
years that we've been bringing it to
South by Southwest and so many amazing
geniuses have worked on the project so
it is like more like an immersive event
and my business partner for the last 10
years was you know by day he was the CTO
of Disney Imagineering and by night he
was the CTO of the our VIP lounge so we
built these like hacker amazing
beautiful art installations and like
coated up raw software to make the
computer talk and like applaud for you
and do all of these magical things it's
like it's like kind of like a mix
between being on a like a ride and at
Burning Man but also like you're just in
Austin and like everything is ok in the
world you don't know where you are but
you're exactly where you want to be oh
my that is a wonderful pitch yeah it
also I don't even really like karaoke
oh you're a favorite yeah something
about this is very appealing to me
has an element of like I grew up my dad
was a like a we did like grew up with
the singsong I feel like the same song
is something we've lost in the world you
know like our generation kind of lost
like someone gets to talk guitar and
just plays all the songs that everyone
knows so the our VIP has like a it's not
like that thing where you do karaoke and
you're up on a stage and you have to
like sweat and shake and you feel all
nervous it's like everybody's singing
with you yeah it's more like church like
we're you know ever since people have
been around they get together in a group
and sing and people really don't do that
as much as they have done the last like
four or seven thousand years it's it's
kind of tapered off a bit you know it's
more like you go to a show and you watch
like Bon Iver sing or Jon Bon Jovi sing
but usually you're like you know
supporting them while they're putting on
the show but like for most of humanity
everyone has sung together as a is this
like tribal ritual and so it's it's more
like the the tribal ization of karaoke
that's right and I do it it kind of
translated to the way that we hand the
set was handled everyone that sort of
abundant nature the PAS everyone was
fully on board because it was this
open-hearted I just express herself kind
of sing a karaoke song it was totally
that and by extension it was like
everybody's spouses and and family and
there was a support system that goes not
just and I feel like this is so like
just question Ben Tara making a movie
and this is how it goes and it's a
community built made push that everybody
wants to I'm just gonna cry talking
about this it was like if you ever get a
chance to make a movie with Karen and
you're an actor like take it because
it's it'll rock your world it's so
refreshing to hear about a collaboration
like this where it's like you guys feel
like a family and that radiates off the
screen in the actual movie but you can
you can get that vibe here that you guys
are really important to each other and I
think that's key for a movie like this
yeah
yes we have to wrap up but in order to
wipe away some of the tears just really
quickly because I can't help myself tell
me about the dog that dog is freaking
adore pink oh gosh loaded questions a
little bit
that is milena mallanna vine tribes dog
she you know she's on this is us and she
was in love on Netflix and Silicon
Valley and she's one of the sheep Lucy
she plays Lucy she's a phenomenal
comedic actress and writer and director
in her own right and she adopted this
dog Hank that she loves and we were
shooting in her house and so Hank is in
the movie Hank was like continually
biting my ankles the entire time and we
couldn't so we just wrote the dog into
the movie yeah I wish I wish I loved the
dog a little bit more I'm sorry I'm
Alana what's happening right now okay
come see mother's little helpers we're
really excited to be world premiering at
South by Southwest the film was inspired
by the life and death of someone who had
a wristband to south-by-southwest year
one who was a drug dealer backstage at
the Continental Club and a rock and roll
awesome person and kind of not so
awesome parents so premiering at South
by Southwest is the absolute dream come
true and we're so excited so we can't
wait for everyone in the world to see it
a huge congratulations I share that
mother's little helpers keep an eye out
for it another thank you to hint water
over here and the supper suite for
having us keep an eye out for more South
by Southwest interviews coming your way
real soon